welcome everyone this is rob sanders
with simply learn
and welcome today we're going to talk
about email marketing tutorial
so buckle up and let's get started
with email marketing tutorial and so
let's start out asking the question
why email marketing so linda
is the owner of an e-commerce company
and
basically she isn't able to take her
leads
leads she's collecting per day per month
and
convert them into customers okay so
customers sign up
but they don't buy her product so she's
left scratching her head wondering
what to do so how she gonna solve the
problem
of converting the lead she gets into
paying customers well look no further
than email mark so you can boost your
sales funnel with the help
of email marketing so email marketing
leads to
email campaigns that lead to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing
email markings also and a
it's a very good way to generate a high
return on investment
so linda thinks this is too good to be
true
you're telling me is a very efficient
way to generate
a return on my investment how expensive
is email marketing well email marketing
is
neither expensive or time consuming
that's the beauty of email marketing
and so linda is now very interested
we've piqued her interest she wants
us to explain email marketing to her
in detail and that's exactly what we're
going to do
we're going to talk about email
marketing in detail so
for everyone out there listening what's
in it for you
why are you going to invest your time
and listening to
simply learn and me talk about email
marketing because
we're going to talk about everything
there is about email marketing
in today's webinar so what is it for
those that aren't really familiar with
the
intricacies of email marketing we're
gonna talk about how to set up email
marketing
we're gonna discuss all the benefits of
email marketing
we're gonna get into a b testing we're
gonna get into the automation of emails
the types of emails how to engage new
users and we're gonna give you a demo
so there's a lot going on in this
webinar like i said buckle up and let's
get started
and talk about what is email marketing
so as i mentioned to linda it's an
efficient way to convert leads into
sales
why because we can send personalized
emails to a specific audience a targeted
audience
if somebody's interested in our product
we can reach out to them via email
it can also be used to remarket
pre-qualified leads
so anybody who's pre-qualified we can go
ahead and communicate with them as well
so email marketing is a very effective
at different stages in the funnel
okay so when i say funnel customer life
cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so
let's talk about each one of these parts
of the
funnel or customer life cycle if you
will so let's start with awareness at
the very top
so email marketing allows customers to
recognize
their problems after which you can
educate them on how your brand can solve
them okay
just like any other marketing channel
somebody's looking for something in need
of something
and we can come to the rescue in this
case we're going to come to the rescue
with email and we can go ahead and
educate them
on what their need is and how we can
collaborate with them
help them educate them solve their
problems with our product
okay so that's what email's going to do
we're going to communicate with them via
email
and we're going to bring awareness to
the problem by solving the problem
that's what email is good for
good for generating awareness for our
brand
for example we can share a newsletter
with our customers so
we're running a cosmetics company we can
basically educate them on the five
important skin care products
that everyone should have okay so we can
get them to click on the call to action
to learn more
so if somebody's having some skin care
issues
or not sure what products to buy you
know an email can
cover that okay the next step in the
customer life cycle is consideration
so customers focused on searching for
relevant products
and compares the products with similar
ones okay
so they're definitely looking they're a
little further in the process they're
educated they know what they're looking
for
so we can really hit them with the right
email we can send a relevant email to
promote our product okay
discover that perfect moisturizer for
your skin
perfect skin moisturizer smooths
hydrates and contains
spf 20. so we got the perfect product
for
that person who's further along the
funnel and
really is ready to purchase that product
so we can hit that person up
with the perfect messaging talk about
purchase the next step
in the life cycle well purchase well
with purchase we can send an email that
encourages that customer
purchase our product by offering them
something
okay by giving an offer for example we
can give a discount
discounts always tend to work so that
moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying
well they can move from consideration to
purchasing because
we're going to offer them a discount
they can't refuse okay so
you know it could beat for a specific
date okay
it could be you know something that's
going to get them excited to buy the
product 20
off of moisturizers pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other
products that we're considering buying
so getting somebody that
extra incentive to purchase the product
goes a long way via email
okay we want to take that next step in
the life cycle and nurture
our relationship with customers to
ensure they're
loyal okay they've already purchased how
do we get them purchased again that's
retention
we want to retain our customers we want
to get them back to buy the same product
or similar products or completely
different products in our inventory so
what do we do we're going to send an
email
we're going to send an email to active
customers okay we're going to
give them an offer just for them
exclusively
just for them in this example we're
gonna give them a combo pack a facial
kit at just
39 and get a sunscreen worth ten dollars
for free
so you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations
on offers key is the offer is
exclusively
just for those who you want to target
and retain as customers because if you
just get somebody to purchase once
it's not going to work those people have
already taken the that step in the
relationship
where they trust your product they
purchase your product now you want to go
ahead and
treat that customer special by giving
them an exclusive offer
and then what we want to do is advocacy
last step
in that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer
into brand advocates okay we want that
customer
to talk about our brand for us we want
them to promote it and talk about it
with their friends
so for example we want to send an email
to those customers to promote our
products
okay so for example we could say hey the
sales of our products for this
particular day
or for this month is going to go to our
favorite non-profit
could be educating poor children or
cleaning up plastic in the ocean
or saving animals we want to be able to
get them to speak on our behalf and say
look guys
this is a really good company you know
they're offering me products exclusively
they've offered me discounts in the past
they have good products they have a lot
of different products
and on top of all that they help they
help the environment they help the needy
okay
they care and so we can go ahead and
provide a call to action for these
customers that are loyal to our brand
and have them share the email with their
friends to spread the word
on you know what we're trying to
accomplish for our nonprofit or
if anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount
for every friend that they get to buy a
product okay it doesn't have to
necessarily be
you know just sharing with friends it
can be that extra incentive
of giving them a discount if they do
share with friends and their friends buy
okay so this is the customer life cycle
and examples of different emails that
you can use at every step
along the way in the life cycle so let's
talk about
email marketing setup so email marketing
set up we have a series of steps that we
need to go through
in order to get our email set up
to go ahead and send out to our target
audience and that first step is we want
to identify that target audience
and create segments so if you've taken
some of my and listened to some of my
webinars in the past about google
analytics
about google ads we talk about
segmenting
so it's about targeting a specific
audience that's what segmenting is
taking a piece of the whole so we don't
want to email all users
on our list all customers maybe we want
to target a specific
segment okay so we want to be able to
identify that segment who is that
segment is it somebody who
or a group of people or you know a
partial list
of our customers who purchase a specific
product
i would say so versus say our entire
list of customers because our entire
list of customers can purchase
a number of different products and so by
targeting a specific
segment of our audience or our customer
base
we can hone in on the message so if they
all have something in common like they
all
bought that moisturizer then we can go
ahead
and be specific with our messaging then
we want to create campaigns and set an
appropriate call to action okay so
what is it that we want to say to these
these people this segment
of users then once you create that
campaign
and and set up the messaging and call to
action we want to test the email
before we actually click send this is a
very important step
test that email before we send
and then when we send the campaigns
immediately or we can
schedule a time so my advice here is
always schedule a time
you want to be able to figure out the
best time
to send that email and then once the
email is sent
whenever that is you want to be able to
analyze performance
and there are some key metrics that you
want to hone
in on when we talk about email marketing
and some of those are
open rates click-through rates okay
response rate
okay so we want to be able to hone in on
certain key
metrics when it comes to emails so
here's what we need to do
create our list add contacts to our list
create
our campaign okay we want to select the
list choose a format
modify the template and then send the
email campaign so
these are some basic checklists that you
want to do so let me give you an example
and go to mailchimp so if i'm in
mailchimp
basically i'm going to create a campaign
okay
so it's an email that i'm going to work
with
and you can see with mailchimp i have
some some examples here regular
automated
plain text or a b test i want to do a
regular email
and i'm just going to call it test and
i'm going to click begin
okay so we want to add our recipients
who are we going to add
so we're going to choose our audience
okay
so we're just going to choose a sample
test for now okay
we can personalize the two fields if we
want
okay so what do we want to do we want to
call people by their first name their
last name the first and last name where
we can customize it just go with
first name to keep it a little bit
personal okay then we have the subject
line here so it's all about
messaging right so whoever we're
targeting
we want to be able to add a message so
we're just gonna say and and subject
line is very key here
so you want to have a subject line
that's really going to resonate
with your audience so whoever that
segment audience is
we want to make sure that the subject
line is going to resonate with
with them so that they can open up that
email okay
so uh we'll just say have any good day
we can make it better just as an example
something that's going to be
attention grabbing if you will okay you
can always tweak the subject line
in fact my advice is always do
a b testing on the subject line so you
can do two
different subject lines with one email
to figure out which one has better open
rates
and then with mailchimp we can go ahead
and design the content
of our email so we're going to click
design email okay we can
select a template we have some save
templates already
okay or we can go with a theme
so mailchimp has a lot of good offers
now there's a lot of different
email platforms out there i particularly
like mailchimp because
of this very feature they have a lot of
good themes here
um a lot of different layouts that you
can use okay
so you know we're gonna showcase that
product
okay and that's the template we're going
to use here so here we go
we're going to showcase our product
we're going to add that photo of our
product here
and we're going to go ahead and put some
nice messaging in here
with some nice call to action we can put
our logo up here for branding
again we can edit the content here so
based
on that segmented list in this example
for linda's company maybe she wants to
target those folks
who bought her moisturizer before her
face moisturizer and she wants to
retarget them
she wants to go ahead and say hey you
guys have bought my product before check
out this
new face moisturizer that we have to
offer so whatever the case is you want
to be able to plan that out ahead of
time you want to be able to plan out who
your audience is
you want to plan out your messaging and
you want to
go ahead and set up the messaging based
on that audience
so once you have the messaging in place
well you're more or less
ready to go okay so once you get the
content all set up
you can schedule that campaign okay and
you can
also add a social post to your campaign
so we can share that information
on social so email integrates nicely
with social media
so again that's that's pretty much what
you need to do here you need to really
think about who it is you want to target
choose those recipients
okay customize it and make it personal
create a good subject line in fact
create two subject lines
and then align that content with that
audience okay that's that's really the
checklist here
so again we look at this checklist
creating our list
who do we want to send the email to so
we added our contacts to the list
we set up the campaign we selected the
list we chose the format
we modified it with a good subject line
with some good messaging
and then we're going to schedule that
email campaign so that's
the checklist to go off of okay so
remember
identify target audience and create
segments
and you create that campaign and in our
case we
did set an appropriate call to action
you know get shopping basically we want
people to shop
our new moisturizer key thing here is
before we send it out we want to test
that email
once everything looks good we're going
to i would advise schedule it but you
can always send the email when you're
ready
i would schedule it at the appropriate
time and day
okay so in this case you don't want to
send an email out on a friday afternoon
okay when people are getting ready for
the weekend you certainly don't want to
send an email out
over the weekend because you're not
going to have many people look and open
it
and you probably don't want to send the
email out on a monday morning when most
people are
getting into the office from a long
weekend and
catching up on emails so from my
experience
you know tuesday wednesday depending on
your time zone i would always say
you know late morning early afternoon
tends to be a good time but
that's why we have performance that's
why we can analyze performance we want
to be able to see what the open rates
are and the click-through rates are so
that we can make adjustments for future
emails so let's talk about
some of those metrics so when you do
send that email
you know we're going to look at that
open run so open rate is the percentage
of the total number of recipients who
open
an email so okay so we basically
you know sent it to x amount of people
minus those emails that have bounced so
let's just say
you know we sent it to a hundred and two
people
okay for simplicity's sake two of those
emails bounced
okay so that means that we've had a
hundred
100 emails that received the email and
let's just say
75 open the email okay we wrote such a
good subject line
that they opened it okay that's 75
that's a 75 open rate that's how you
measure open rate
click through rate okay so if they open
it we hope that they click on something
and so for all of those emails that were
delivered
okay in this case a hundred how many
actually did click on our call to action
so let's just say 75 opened it
out of the 100 that's a 75 open rate but
of the hundred that actually were
delivered let's just say
we had 25 that actually clicked on the
call to action and so
that's 25 okay and so you want to be
able to measure
not only who opens it but who clicks on
the call to action
so that's click-through rate for email
marketing and then response rate so it's
the percentage of the total recipients
who clicked on a link of your email
campaign and actually completed the
action
so in our example we're trying to get
people to click on the shopping call to
action
and get them to purchase so we set 100
emails
and of the 25 who actually clicked
we had 10 who actually took action and
purchase
so 10 divided by 100 is 10
so you have open rate click to rate and
response rate those are some
key metrics for email marketing okay the
first step is you got to get people to
open it
that's where the subject line is so
important click-through rate
that's where the messaging and call to
action is so important we want to get
people to click on that call to action
and then the response rate we want them
to buy so those are our three key
metrics related to email marketing
so let's take a look at an example if we
go back
to our email marketing platform
mailchimp in this example we're going to
take a look
at some reports so most email marketing
platforms
have reporting functionality built in
and so in this case
what we want to do is we want to be able
to take a look at the open rate
click-through rates
of the emails that have been sent out
previously so
here we could see our april email coupon
versus tools promo
okay so we've had basically you know
opens
and clicks so 14 open rate 1.4
click-through rate okay so the march
email that went out
did a little bit better 19 open two and
a half percent on the click-through rate
so here we could see how many people
actually were sent
how many open it and how many clicks so
this is a mailchimp makes it very
easy for us to measure you know open and
click rates
and then we can measure by revenue as
well based on
the campaign so that's measuring the
response rate
so it's all built in so most email
marketing platforms
have open rate and click rate already
built into the functionality
so you can measure those two metrics
against
any email so let's talk about the
benefits of email marketing
so what are some of the benefits well
we've already mentioned to linda
that it's cost effective it's time
saving
real time marketing less intrusive
builds credibility increases visibility
and brand awareness
and it's an easy way to track roi these
are all the benefits
for email marketing we're gonna go talk
about some of these now
so basically when we talk about cost
effective
you know some email marketing platforms
charge based on the number of users who
you send the email to time saving well
you saw how quick it took me
to set up that email campaign the key is
figuring out
who you want to send it to when we talk
about real-time marketing you know we're
sending this
email out basically in real time
trying to meet our customers needs at
the
right time it's less intrusive because
we can customize the emails okay we can
as you saw i can put first name
in there to make it more personal so
when something's more personal it's less
intrusive
especially if it's a segment that
already knows your brand
okay builds credibility hey we gain
credibility
when we offer exclusive offers to repeat
customers or
you know try and build advocacy by
working with nonprofits
okay it increases visibility and brand
awareness why because
you know we could send our email out to
a large
group of people and that's a good way
to generate brand awareness and as you
saw
we can easily measure you know not only
open rates click rates but
roi so how many people from that email
went on and purchased so we can measure
that it's very
easy to measure email so let's move into
a b
testing so a b testing is
key to email marketing okay so in email
marketing
gaining high open rates and
click-through rates will result in more
website visitors and sales okay in
theory that's what's supposed to happen
we get more opens we get more people to
click we get more people to click we're
going to get more people to purchase
okay but it's not as easy as it sounds
so how do we make that possible
well we're going to do that via a b
testing i've already mentioned it when i
set up my example
campaign in mailchimp i stressed and
stressed and stressed
that we need to have two subject lines
go out
per email okay so before i stress that
again
let me just reiterate what a b testing
is and a b
testing is a method to analyze which of
the two email campaign strategies most
effective
in terms of high open rates and click
rates okay so in this case
an a b test and you can send out two
emails you can send out two subject
lines you can send out two call to
actions
you're just really what you're doing is
you're testing one against the other
that's what a b testing is and so in my
example i
talked about that subject line so for
better results a b
testing can be done with the subject
line can also be done with the email
content
so the subject line impacts the open
rate okay so i wrote a subject line i
don't even know how that subject line is
going to perform but if i write a second
subject line
then i'll be able to basically give
myself a
better chance of getting a better open
rate because i'm offering up
two different subject lines likewise for
email content so
the subject line and email content are
the most important elements
so we want to be able to test them if
they're interesting intriguing
uh attention grabbing then it's gonna in
the case of subject lines
a result in open rates if the content
itself is interesting
engaging a good offer good call to
action
then the click rates are going to be
increased so we want to be able to serve
up variations for
our audience so we want to consider an
example of an a b
test where linda has set up two
variations
of the email campaign as an example so
she's gonna
send two different subject lines to test
which one generates more open rates
because that's what
subject line a b testing is going to do
one of them
is going to have a higher open rate okay
so in our example here
linda sends version a of the email to
50 of the recipients with the subject
line
three important strategies to increase
your open rate well version
b which is sent to the other 50 percent
has the subject line three important
strategies to increase
your open rate so the only difference
here is
three and three the number three spelled
out well
because she sent out two different
subject lines she's going to now
be able to measure the success of that a
b test
okay and it just so happens version a
has a higher open rate
numbers always tend to work in subject
lines by the way
so linda sends version a of the email to
fifty percent
of the recipients okay eighty dollars
today but ninety dollars tomorrow
and version b to the remaining fifty
percent eighty dollars today
ninety dollars tomorrow and the only
really succinct
difference here is using the word but
versus a comma
and she sent that email out and that
email went out
and the date is coming in and she's
gonna measure the success of that a b
test well version b has the higher
open rate you know we want to be short
succinct
and stay away from those conjugations
like but okay
it tends to have a negative connotation
so the shorter
more direct email our subject line 80
today 90 tomorrow not so passive
more direct and that tend to have the
higher open rate so you always want to
test those subject lines to generate
high open rates another example here
version a
again gets 50 with the subject line
uh-oh
your prescription is expiring version b
your prescription is expiring you folks
listen to this webinar right now i
wonder
which one you think will perform go
ahead and put your comments
right below this video i'm curious what
version of the subject line you would
open so let's go ahead
and measure the success of the a b test
okay so she sent the email out
two different subject lines fifty
percent got one
subject line the other fifty percent got
the other subject line
and it just so happens version a uh-oh
your prescription is expiring there's a
little bit of a
you know personalization to that you
know for me your prescription is
expiring
seems to be a little bit more you know
command-ish
hey your prescription's expiring so we
expect you to purchase
where you have a little uh-oh in front
it's like hey
you know i think your prescription is
expiring maybe you should think about
renewing it okay i think that's how
that's interpreted at least that's how i
interpret it so i would probably go
ahead and click on that
email with that subject line so you
could see subtle
differences in the subject lines make a
big difference in open rates
so in order to keep improving those open
rates
you need to continue and not continue
should always do
subject line testing always because one
subject line is always going to have a
better open rate than the other
so always do a b testing when it comes
to subject lines
and email content for that matter okay
so
we're always going to do continuous a b
testing so with continuous a b testing
we can test
very various elements of the email so
you can always test the sender's name
the subject line the copy the call to
action the design the imagery
there's a lot of different elements you
can test
with emails for example sender's name
okay so you want to personalize it as
much as you can okay
you don't want to do a no reply you want
it to come from a human being
in this case sam okay at least that's
what i think let's see what the
test states no surprise version a
has the higher open rate if you
customize these things and personalize
them
then it goes a long way sending an email
from a no reply is not a good
best practice let's talk about
the subject line again uh so we got
webinar
increase your email open rates webinar
increase your email open rates
so the webinar is dynamic on version a
okay so we're sending that out and
because it's dynamic
that's going to you know beat out the
static
webinar increase your email open rates a
lot more elements we can test here
so for example the email copy so learn
some easy ways to increase your email
open rates join us on may 10
2019 7 p.m for an interactive discussion
with our experts
well version b is more personalized it's
a same message
but we're actually addressing someone
specific in this case
rachel so we can measure the success of
the a b
test but it's no surprise that anything
that's
customized that comes from somebody a
name
you know with a dynamic email subject
line
is going to perform better it's going to
increase open rates
and it's going to increase click rates
so we can also
test that call to action the difference
here is
coloring save my seat yellow versus save
my c blue
again go ahead and play along here if
you're watching this
go ahead and add a comment and just see
if you're right do you think it's blue
or you think it's yellow on the call to
action color
does go a long way in email marketing so
let's measure the success of this a b
test and it just so happens yellow is
going to perform better why does yellow
perform better than blue
what's more positive plus it it kind of
resonates a little bit stronger
and easier okay it stands out a little
bit better
it's not as pastely and dull as this
shade of blue we're using so you can see
here
we're testing every bit of the elements
of the email
anything from the from to the subject
line
to the message to the call to action
and so at the end of the day you know
you want to be able to
send out the best email that's gonna
give you the best results
so we're gonna send that out the
entirety of the email
and we could see version a looks a lot
better and why does version a look a lot
better in this example because
look at the font size is a little bit
bigger
version b font size smaller harder to
read that's another thing you can test
larger fonts tend to do a little bit
better now you don't want to go
overboard and have them
you know 48 points or 50 points and plus
you know 14 versus 12 goes a long way
we can continue testing we can test
imagery
you can see here we have a hand aligned
with the call to action they just look
different that's all
version a has one type of hand version b
has the other type of hand
aligned with the call to action let's go
ahead and send out that test and see
what works
well version b works why the hand stands
out a little bit more clear it doesn't
blend in
with the call to action so you can see
we're testing different
elements here and we're always improving
and adding to what's working
so we started out with a no reply versus
somebody's name then we move to a
subject line
then we move to personalization then we
move to
you know call to action then we move to
an increased
font meaning the design and then we're
adding imagery so we're
constantly improving the email with each
test
eventually you're going to get to a
point where you know the email is going
to be good and you're going to
just continue to test different options
on it
to continue to increase open rates click
rates and response rates
final output looks like this again that
personalized email
response from sam versus no reply
you know we got a nice dynamic subject
line
gotta personalize the email to rachel
with larger font
okay we got a nice call to action that
stands out
with a nice image to accompany that so
we've tested
all these different elements this is the
best combination
based on everything we tested so when we
get that email to go
this is what it's going to look like in
the future but guess what we're not
going to stop
testing so we can continue to test those
subject lines continue to test the
messaging and continue to test the email
design
continue to test different call to
actions continue to test different
images
you're never going to stop testing with
email marketing okay
so let's switch over to how to optimize
the subject line
subject line is such a key component to
email marketing
so as we showed you in the last segment
we tested a subject line
and we used a number the number three
versus three spelled out
just so happens that numbers tend to do
a little bit better
they're shorter easier to read and they
resonate better
so including number in your subject line
you can include an emoji in your subject
line your emails come a long way
emojis aren't just social media based
you can use emojis in subject lines i'd
highly recommend it you know i just sat
on an email last month with the subject
line about
you know spring showers bring may
flowers and guess what emoji i had in
that subject line
a flower okay may sound cheesy but it
goes a long way
okay so we want to personalize those
subject lines for better
open rate okay when i say personalize
don't be so stale
remember that subject line we tested
uh-oh just putting
uh-oh in there made it sound like we
actually cared it was a little bit
personal it wasn't so personal you
weren't dressing a specific
person but one little word goes a long
way in a subject line because when
people get emails and they read emails
and a lot of people are inundated with
emails
the subject line is what they're reading
first and just by
personalizing it adding a number adding
an
emoji
just making it positive and easy to read
they're likely to open an email
so personalized email messages can
improve
click through rate and open rates as
well so you want to personalize your
email as much as you can
whether that be from the from field to
putting that person's
name in the salutation so personalized
subject lines have been found to
increase
open rates by up to 50 percent so don't
come across
as spammy come across as you know who
your audience is and you're talking to
them and then
you want to prefer title case subject
lines
so title case subject lines for example
when i say
title case game of thrones is my
favorite show
every initial letter in that title
is capitalized okay you can go with the
sentence case game of thrones is my
favorite show
it doesn't stand out as much of course
if you go with lower case
it definitely doesn't stand out it looks
illiterate and
somebody's probably not going to open it
so you always go with that title case
the
every initial letter gets capitalized
so how to optimize that subject line
well watch the length of your subject
line you want to be
conscious of character counts so 17 to
24
characters you want to keep it short
succinct
and to the point but personalized with
an emoji
with initial caps on each word to make
it stand out
but you have to do that within 17 and 24
characters
so according to campaign monitor the
ideal length of a subject line
is up to 24 characters and they're more
likely to boost those email rates
okay so keep it short make it impactful
make it personalized like i mentioned
before
if you get too long then it may get cut
off and it may not
have the same impact as something
shorter so that's why we always
recommend
keeping it up to about 24 characters
okay if you go over by a couple
characters
not the end of the world but try and
stay within that range
develop a sense of urgency okay so when
we say sense of urgency
we mean sense of urgency meaning if that
coupon is going to
know you want to let people know it's
gonna expire that day or the next day or
within a few days
okay so you can use things like hurry up
or limit
offer or limited stock or offer expires
on
okay so add a bit of sense of urgency i
mean
sky's not falling here but if that
coupon's expiring
at the end of the week you probably want
to mention something
to the effect of hey offers expiring or
hurry up
so let's talk about optimizing your
email content so we focused a lot on
subject lines let's talk about the email
content itself
so some ways to optimize email content
are we want to send the content that is
relevant to
customer expectations so content needs
to match that expectation
we want to use bullet points to make the
content readable
we want to follow logical structure we
want to use compelling imagery
and fur design emails with responsive
designs and what we mean by responsive
design
is hey most people are going to be
checking that email
on their mobile phone okay so make sure
when you design the email
it's also going to be good not just on
desktop but on tablet and mobile as well
and then of course just goes without
saying but avoid grammatical mistakes
go ahead and spell checked it and that's
why we put an emphasis on testing your
email before you actually send it and
when you actually
send an email test email don't send it
to yourself
send it to colleagues you know send it
to another group a fresh set of eyes
a fresh set of eyes like it's going to
be able to pick out
that misspelled word that you overlooked
so
i can't stress the sending of the test
email because
it's going to be able to you know in a
way
ensure that you're doing everything on
this list in addition to grammatical
mistakes
you know the person who's receiving your
test email your colleague at work
may be looking at that email on their
mobile phone and if it doesn't look good
to them
they're gonna let you know some other
ways to optimize email content
personalization so we did that on the a
b testing you always want to personalize
it
question is hey do i use first name do i
use first and last name
well guess what you can test that but
you want to personalize it okay you want
to choose the right fonts and
colors for your email so when we were
going through some examples on testing
you know i always tend to go a little
bit larger on the font
but you can play around with it i don't
think you should probably use
white lettering on a black background
that just
is not very good or best practice
but go ahead and try it if you want okay
you can always play around
and test these but you want to choose
something that's really going to
resonate
with the recipient of the email okay you
want to build a rapport with customers
by
sharing insights they value for example
the beginning of this webinar we talked
about advocacy we talked about
you know sharing with them some of the
non-profits that
we work with as a company okay if we
have a
you know cosmetics company and we have
different products like moisturizers
and facial creams we may want to state
that hey we don't use
any animals in the testing of these
products you know we're pro
animal we're not you know we're not
going to use animals in the testing of
our products
and that probably resonates with a lot
of your customers so you want to
go ahead and build a rapport with those
customers by sharing those insights
okay and use recipient names and you
always want to
personalize it then add a clear call to
action at the end you always want to
have that call to action
regardless of what the email is hey it
could be just a simple
read more or hey donate it doesn't have
to
always be so hardcore in terms of hey
purchase our product
that could be a turn off especially if
you're sending emails out once a week to
your customer base they're constantly
hammering them
with buy now buy now by now they're
going to get turned off so you want to
mix
up the call to actions and that goes
back to the very first step
and what kind of email are you going to
send out and who are you going to send
it to so you have to align those two
with somebody who doesn't even know who
your brand is
you're not going to put a call to action
of buy now
you're probably going to say hey check
us out we have some cool
stuff for you okay let's talk about
automating emails email automation
so triggered emails are sent to
customers
based on an event date or user behavior
okay so when we say
an event could be a special occasion
like mother's day okay could be a date
like a birthday or anniversary or
specific day of the week
could also be based on user behavior you
know a good example of user behavior
are those who abandon the car you can
trigger an email
in fact mailchimp has remarketing
functionality
so with mailchimp hey if somebody
abandons our car
we can have an email triggered and we
can send an email
a nice email that says hey we noticed
you didn't finish
purchasing our product and i'm not sure
what happened but hey here's another 10
off or you can always just make product
recommendations as well but
you want to react to user behavior and
use the emails to your advantage for
that
so you want to take be cognizant of
different occasions
you want to be cognizant of special
events holidays
etc and user behavior so these types of
emails can be automated because
you know when they might happen or that
they are probably going to happen so
auto responder emails are sent at
frequent intervals based on the behavior
of subscribers
so for example if somebody purchases
something then you're gonna get an email
that probably says hey thank you for
your purchase another email that says
hey your products on its way
and then another email that says hey
your package your product has been
delivered
so that's an example of an automated
email that goes out if somebody
purchases your product you probably want
to thank them for that
then you probably want to let them know
that hey it's on its way
here you could track it and then again
you want to confirm that it's been
delivered but thank them again
so that's an example of an automated
email that goes out okay let's talk
about
types of email campaigns so
we have different types of email
campaigns and the first is a newsletter
so with email newsletters subscribers
are connected and informed about product
updates
so it doesn't necessarily have to be a
product they buy it could be a product
they subscribe to
like software okay you always want to be
able to send out that newsletter to let
them know what's going on
with your product are there upcoming
product updates ahead
is there one that just happened is there
a webinar that discusses
the new product update so that's what
the newsletter is going to do inform
the end user about the update so how to
optimize
okay so you stack your email content
create a compelling header
share different variety of useful
content like videos articles etc with
those recipients
and then follow a consistent schedule so
that's how you handle a newsletter you
should always create a compelling header
but if you're going to send a newsletter
make sure you support it with some good
information like a video that they can
go watch or an article that
will follow up on what you put in the
email or
promoting that webinar that's going to
talk about that product update
so example here is a newsletter that
gets sent
out and here you can see it talks about
business process
it's got some nice imagery in there okay
call to action
it's got a little bit of everything in
this email template okay
and that's when we talk about stack your
email content that's what you talk about
stacking
you can see at the top it's got work
with the industry best
subscribe now okay they validate that
with 25 years of top notch service
then they talk about hiring the best
talent and you got the next bit of
content below that so that's stacked
email content
okay that's going to be supported by
compelling header and then
they're going to share a variety of
different content in there
like there could be clicks in there to
video videos and articles
moving on from newsletters to
promotional emails so we want to be able
to drive revenue by
sending special offers through
promotional email
okay so how do we optimize a promotional
email well we want to personalize the
campaign
okay promotional we want to definitely
personalize it
include time sensitive offers we want to
get people to react
okay so that means you know adding a
sense of urgency in the title
and the subject line okay you can send
offer emails on holidays if it's
mother's day
hey send it a couple days before or even
send it on
if it's personalized then you can say
hey so and so
we know you're a mother here take 20 off
i mean that kind of personalized email
with an offer goes a long way
here you an example from toms limited
time
extra 20 off all styles they include the
code in there
okay again you can see the the
sensitivity
and the sense of urgency with the
limited time
another email campaign type and
personally one of my favorites is
abandoned cart
so abandon card emails i like working
with a banned card emails because
you know we want people to purchase and
as much as you try on your email
marketing campaign to drive traffic to
the website
and as hard as the website works to get
people to convert
through the shopping cart it's never
gonna be a hundred percent
and so abandon cart emails give us that
extra incentive to get that person back
to the shopping cart to purchase okay so
these emails are shared with customers
who have added
product to their cart but didn't finish
through the checkout process in other
words they didn't
purchase the product so it's an
effective way of sales recovery it gives
us
another opportunity to reach out to that
person
who just is almost there but not quite
ready to finish the purchase so what are
we going to do we're going to send out
an email for those that abandon their
car and we're going to use a simple
abandoned cart email template okay you
want to be simple here
you don't want to get complicated we're
trying to make this easy for them to
finish
purchasing the products and we want to
definitely personalize it
okay we want to send a series of email
reminders
okay in your email reminder add a
product image
so as customized as it can be it could
be
even the product image of what they've
abandoned
and that's the best practice so if it's
that facial moisturizer that linda's
trying to promote
and she can't quite get enough people to
finish
purchasing the product they're they're
banning the cart
well she can certainly send out the
abandoned cart email okay
so for example you want to personalize
it
hey you forgot to complete your order
you left something in your car can we
help
email too hi there so and so items in
your shopping cart are selling out
quickly
it's a gentle reminder okay so come
across a little bit different here
okay email three hey so and so 20
off on your cart valid until so and so
offer on your favorite product so the
first email that went out
and the series of emails hey you forgot
something hey is there anything we can
do to help you
complete the product purchase email too
is just that gentle reminder hey you're
selling out quickly
you might want to purchase that product
and the email three is to really help
them along
by saying hey here's 20 off valid until
so and so
so just a small series of emails that go
out
try and get somebody back into the
shopping cart
okay let's talk about re-engagement
campaign so in a re-engagement campaign
it's a series of emails sent to
inactive email subscribers so what it
does is it boosts engagement and helps
to maintain a high
inbox placement ratio inbox placement
ratio so we want to be able to
make sure that we're getting people back
on our subscriber list
so how are we going to optimize for
something like this this is
now these are difficult type of email
campaigns we're trying to re-engage with
people who are inactive
so we want gamification to re-engage
subscribers or
we want to prefer subject lines like hey
we've been missing you
or did we do something wrong okay we can
run a poll or
competition to re-engage with our
subscribers so for example
hey we'd hate to miss your birthday go
ahead and update your account this is a
starbucks
email so we'd hate to miss your birthday
so
it's that you know message of missing
you you can always
soften or sweeten the deal with an offer
as well
so that brings us to how to engage with
new subscribers
so we just talked about re-engaging with
inactive
we want to talk about engaging with new
subscribers so how to engage with new
subscribers well
thank your subscribers for joining
create
clear and compelling subject lines that
is a must
regardless of what type of email you
send out you
always want to send out that compelling
subject line
okay notice the good examples within
17 to 24 characters know the
ideal time to message okay again
sending it on the weekends not gonna
work okay sending it out during the
weekday
you know in the morning mid-morning you
know
sometimes in the afternoon works really
depends on who your audience is
weekends probably aren't going to work
they avoid the no reply center name
again
personalize it you're either sam or rob
or so and so sally
you know let them know that the emails
come from a real person
okay because if it doesn't come from a
person most people
aren't going to respond okay we want to
let our subscribers know
the privacy policy so we want to let
them know that we abide by
a privacy policy okay that's you know
getting you know straight with people
who are new they don't know your brand
they don't know your privacy policy
they don't want to get spammed in other
words so putting that out there
makes you more transparent and
trustworthy okay and again
personalization always personalize if
it's new
if it's inactive repeat customers loyal
customers lifetime customers
you should always personalize and you
should always be courteous
and always thank them and then prefer
attractive email designs okay
work with something that's going to be
eye catchy and then
most important most important is include
an unsubscribe link i can't tell you
how annoying it is to get an email
and not have the unsubscribe link there
that makes me
want to unsubscribe even if it was a
good email
i still look for that because maybe
they're good company but they're
spamming me they're sending me too many
emails so maybe i want to unsubscribe or
change my subscription
so you always want to include that
unsubscribed link in fact in the united
states it's actually
law so there is regulation about that
around that so you need to include an
unsubscribe link it's just
common courtesy if anything so it bodes
well
okay of course you don't want people to
unsubscribe but you don't want them to
get annoyed either okay let's talk about
email marketing tools so we talked about
mailchimp
so there are plenty of email marketing
platforms out there
i use mailchimp i've used a few in the
past
like marketo i've used zoho vertical
response
so there are a lot of different tools
out there here some of them
again mailchimp marketo marketo is a
marketing automation tool or system
and marketo is good for sending those
automated emails
hubspot convertkit send in blue
aweber i mean these are just some of the
many that are out there
okay so let's show a demo again of an
email marketing campaign
so let's show an example of a newsletter
that one of my clients had sent out and
so this is paul ekman group paul ekman
dr
ekman inspired the tv show lied to me so
well known in the industry of micro
expressions he's the
aforementioned expert in micro
expressions
and he sends out email marketing
campaigns and
he sends out a monthly newsletter so
this is a a newsletter was sent out in
november 2018
and if we look at it you can see here
okay it's stacked content
nice imagery okay respectful
disagreements how to deal with
disagreements
this holiday season so really relevant
personalized because and timely because
it was set in november
during the holiday season so got some
nice imagery there
okay we got content in here and then
right below that on the stack content
what do we have
final hour 24 hours 25
off so that sense of urgency built in
to the email then here you go you have
some other content in there
based on the face of contempt okay just
an example of
a micro expression and then right below
that what do we see we see a call to
action
learn how to use microexpressions to
your advantage so
call to action here then we have some
more information here with the learn
more
so a newsletter that went out basically
really a blog post built into the email
with some nice content
reminding folks hey they have 24 hours
got some other
useful information in the email so
this email went out very timely 98 000
okay see subject line here controversy
respectful disagreements and
thanksgiving
okay could the subject line be a little
bit shorter yes
possibly but if we look at the open rate
15
16 open rate okay industry average
in education and training is 18 okay so
they're close to the industry average
on the click rate you know 1.6 percent
on the click rate
industry average 2.1 so we can see
what the top links were clicked okay so
they have a lot of links and and
mailchimp will help you measure what
links were clicked the most
who subscribed what subscriber with the
most opens
we can see opens by country but that's
an example of a newsletter
for this particular company okay stacked
content
okay sense of urgency okay you can see
the subject line
timely newsletter so this is a
a good i think a good example of an
email
for the time of year okay so let's go
over the checklist again
for email marketing so good reminders on
the checklist this is a checklist
you want to make sure all boxes are
checked
you want to create interesting subject
lines as they boost your open rates
direct correlation with open rates is
subject line okay you want to keep your
content relevant and consistent with
your brand you want to check the sender
name
okay so you want to make sure not only
is it personalized but
the name aligns with the email address
okay you should always personalize
always personalize the subject line and
the email copy text
meaning you know don't just say hello
say hello
to sally pete rob michael
etc always include an unsubscribe
link in emails okay give people the
option to unsubscribe
okay you can always re-engage them
another way or later on
but you don't want to irk any one of
your potential customers
use a b testing we talked about a b
testing the webinar there's
lots of different elements we can test
from subject line to content
to font to call to action to imagery
to subject line etc there's no shortage
of elements in an email you can test
you want to use welcome emails to build
good customer relationships so when
somebody signs up for a newsletter
send out a welcome news email to them
hey welcome
thank you for signing up you should
always
segment your list based on user behavior
so you have a group of people who
purchase product a
customize your email for product a but
you know you can mention
product b and c in there but know who
your audience is
so you can talk to your audience and you
can always ask your subscribers to
update their preferences as well
because you want to make sure you're
sending out emails to the right person
right address
okay this is a short checklist now we
can expand upon this but these are some
of the
most of the key items when it comes to
email marketing
some other items on the checklist
include features such as countdown
timers and live polls
okay make it interactive okay choose the
right email frequency
don't be sending emails three or four
times a week
once a week is probably as much as you
want to go
depending on what it is if somebody
purchases something
then you probably want to send an email
thanking them for the purchase
another one letting another product has
been shipped
and another one with thank you the
product has
been received reward those subscribers
send out exclusive offers okay make sure
your emails are optimized for mobile
that means
send out test emails and check it on
different devices create a schedule okay
you can automate these emails so create
a schedule
that makes the most sense have a footer
and a header in the email
and in that footer and header is going
to be some information
okay just like i showed you with the
micro expressions
there was a footer and header avoid spam
filters
okay how do you avoid spam filters well
apply best practices
i mean don't have spammy subject lines
have an
actual name associated with the reply to
email
and and split up your list as well when
you send out one email
to 150 000 people it could probably get
caught up in some spam
so segment out your audiences keep your
audience list short so that your
messaging
can be specific to the audience that's
going to help avoid spam
and then of course you always want to
measure and analyze results
so remember a lot of these email
marketing platforms
have the results built in especially
open rates
and click rates some key takeaways from
today's webinar we talked about what is
email marketing
so email marketing really is an
effective way
to really give get a good message out to
a target audience
plenty of benefits doesn't cost a lot of
money to do email marketing
okay you can do it in real time it
doesn't take a lot of time
okay and you can get some roi out of it
we also talked about a b testing that's
a very
key component to email marketing if
you're going to do email marketing
at the very least test those subject
lines but there's so many different
elements you can test
okay we talked about the types of
different email campaigns
from newsletter to promotional
abandonment cart to re-engagement
re-engaging those inactive users
so each type of email campaign is going
to contain a different way to talk to
them
okay how to engage with new users okay
so we went
over a best practices list for engaging
with new users
some of which means and personalizing
you always use an attractive email you
want to come across
the very first time with the right way
always always always create a clear and
compelling subject line
if it's a new or returning recipient
you always want a clear and compelling
subject line
and then there's plenty of email
marketing tools you know i showed you
mailchimp mailchimp has
some really good features in it if i go
back to mailchimp again just to drive
home the point okay so
you you can look at specific look at
really specific data
per email it has reporting built in it
has all these nice little templates
built in
so you can create a template okay you
can leverage a template
and there's lots of templates you can
use they even have a content studio
so it has a lot of features built
into the platform this is just mailchimp
i mean
marketo and hubspot and aweber and all
these other platforms
do very similar things you just have to
pick the one that works for you
the best so i want to thank you for
attending today's
webinar on email marketing if you need
any more
information please visit simplylearn.com
if you have anything to add
certainly go ahead and comment below
this video we'd love
to get your comments on the subject and
of course we'll respond accordingly
thank you again and look forward to
seeing you on future webinars
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn nerd up and get certified
click here